you know everybody's gonna say that we
could be
and should be super bowl contenders yeah
we know that every every person that
plays in the nfl should believe that but
i've always firmly believed you set your
own expectations nobody else really
matters no offense to you guys you can
write all you want about what we have
but
if we don't set goals for ourselves and
believe in those and work for it doesn't
really matter
that's baker mayfield talking about the
expectations for the cleveland browns in
2019 and they are sky high and we play
that because we're going to play one of
our games here we've got like looks like
his top button was button there you know
just to let you know it looked like he
was uh top button swagging can we check
that do we have a still friend we're
pretty sure it looked like it was i'm
gonna i i i
uh yeah you're really seriously well yep
okay all right it's close
i'm sure that hey let me do this while
we proceed yes the crew will find a
photo of baker mayfield from yesterday
that will either confirm or debunk the
belief that your ridiculous stylistic
choice is finally catching on after all
these years it's not catching up
these guys they're the kind of guys that
do it and i go that looks cool i'm gonna
do it so i'm really copying people like
that more than not yes wait a minute
wait a minute maybe maybe i'm a little
maybe i'm a little messed up in the head
yeah maybe i've done this show too many
times i clearly recall you defending
your look by saying that you've been
doing it since you were eight years old
i have been doing it my whole life but i
also have seen these guys like odell and
jarvis over the years do it and it gives
you the more confidence to go you know
that is a good look look at that yeah i
feel good about it so they're they're
the the fashion trendsetters not you or
me i know that
so if i would start doing it does that
mean you would stop oh but jarvis jarvis
on the left has top button swag
but you're busted i know you're right
and yeah but jarvis does jarvis has the
top button button so uh i gotta give it
to jarvis all right so he is the either
copying chris or chris is copying him
either way
let's get to why we're here as i was
saying earlier we have some rotating
games we play it reminds me that price
is right where you never quite know what
game you're going to get today's game is
what's more likely and we're going to
start with baker mayfield and and i want
you to focus on this one chris you got
to think about this who's more likely to
win the mvp in 2019 baker mayfield or
any quarterback from the nfc wow well
i'm gonna go with any quarterback in the
nfc i'm gonna i mean again i expect big
things from baker mayfield certainly
with that offense and his talent and
everything about it but damn uh there's
this guy called oh aaron rodgers
yeah he's won a few of them you know
russell wilson okay i'm gonna throw him
in the mix there and then you got cam
newton and matt ryan who are also in the
nfc drew brees his course is still there
i gotta go with the nfc as much as i
love baker mayfield
hey i always go with the field except
when the other choice is the patriots i
always go with the field yeah right and
you you got to go with the field on this
one too many great quarterbacks in the
nfc and also also because there are so
many great
afc you may not have that dominant team
that is going to generate your mvp
candidate it's more likely that there
will be a dominant team that rises up in
the nfc because there's more of a vacuum
there with all these great players who
are now part of the afc and all these
great young quarterbacks they're going
to kind of cannibalize each other that
14-2 team i think this year is more
likely to come from the nfc and that
14-2 team more likely to generate the
mvp and if it's carson wentz healthy all
year carson wentz would be all the guys
you mentioned he's the one i would put
at the top of the list but the key for
him is staying healthy all year long all
right
more likely to draft a quarterback in
the first round it's only coming up
three weeks and two days away the
raiders or the giants oh this is a good
one here i'm gonna go with the giants
okay i mean the raiders i don't put
anything outside the realm of john
gruden when it comes to the quarterback
situation
i guess it's one of those though i just
gotta see it to believe it i mean the
way he's defended derek carr the way he
talked about it at the end of the year
you know just few comments i've heard
here and there i am going to say that
the new york giants are the team that
drafts a quarterback now i don't know if
it'll be with numbers the number six
pick it might be a pick number 17 but uh
i guess the only way i really look at
the raiders dabbling in the quarterback
is if somehow kyler murray was on the
board at number four
then maybe john gruden would do it and i
don't think that'll happen so that's why
i go with the giants
yeah but you know what yesterday you
were making a very compelling case as to
why maybe the giants aren't going to
draft a quarterback at all this year
with the rumor that maybe they'd keep
eli manning for 2020 so you delay the kc
model by a year but i guess between the
two teams if i had to pick one i'd say
the giants as well yeah because i don't
think murray's gonna be there at four
and i agree with you that would be the
only circumstance where i think that the
raiders would go quarterback in the
first round and you know unless there's
some guy they secretly love and they get
him with the cowboys pick at number 27 i
believe and we we also can't rule out
that possibility of a team that needs a
quarterback jumping back in at number 32
in a trade with the patriots maybe the
giants would do that if there's a guy
still there and they want to get him on
a five-year contract a guy they really
like that's a possibility as well but
between the two i agree with you the
giants over the raiders all right the
next question comes from a couple of
april fool's day gags we saw yesterday
mike evans of the buccaneers supposedly
now a full-time defensive back in
addition to a full-time receiver that's
not true although they did try very hard
to sell it tom brady his first tweet
ever announces his retirement
from football which nobody fell for i'd
like to think nobody felt for that at
all but it was kind of funny that he
would try that so what is more likely
which of the april fool's day jokes more
likely to come true tom brady eventually
announcing his retirement on social
media like gronk did a week and a half
ago or mike evans playing non-hail mary
plays on defense well i think when all
said and done i mean i'm going to go
with brady announcing his retirement on
social media at some point i mean it's
just a question of whether that when
that happens but at wha is hashtag lfg
if you're watching on tv is that what i
think it is is that careful yeah yes
careful that's effing go is that like
yeah
oh
we did it i did it i didn't say that
word but yes that would be the one i
would go with i don't think the tampa
bay buccaneers as much as mike evans
might want to play defense uh he is a
special receiver kind of the unforgotten
man in the nfl at receiver one of the
best in the league in the conversation
with odell and antonio and deandre
hopkins aj green julio mike evans is
right there and i don't think they're
ever going to let him play defense other
than on the hail mary snaps
yeah and and look i i
now that tom brady is on twitter and he
has like 300 000 followers in one day
he's going to have a gigantic following
between instagram facebook and twitter
and it'll be a perfect opportunity for
him to control the message just like
gronk did you control the message you
control the narrative you set the agenda
you communicate directly to everyone
what you are doing and i agree with you
that of the two it's far more likely
that tom brady would announce his
retirement on social media all right one
more speaking of gronk who retired via
social media a week and a half ago
julius peppers retired earlier this year
which guy is more likely to be the first
ballot hall of famer they're going to be
in competition the same year for a spot
in the hall of fame is it gronk is it
peppers gosh i mean they're both going i
think first ballot hall of famers so i
just like would like to clarify that but
i guess at the end of the day i mean
julius peppers is fourth all time on the
all-time sack list that's how special of
a player he is
but still at the same time i think that
gronk is the more likely guy
i do i just think grunk and again i
don't want to knock julius peppers in
any shape way or form because dan did he
put a lot of fear in my butt uh in a lot
of football games i had a peek over my
back uh back my backside a lot because i
was worried about him but gronkowski i
just think the impact he had on football
the impact he had on the greatest team
we've seen in the history of the nfl
over the last nine years to win three
super bowls you know be a part of two
other teams that lost super bowls and i
know he didn't play in one of them but
regardless uh i got to go with gronk i
just think he's a little bit more
special for his position than maybe even
julius peppers
you know i'm torn on this because on one
hand i would say that pepper's longevity
right would make him more likely
but but here's the thing and we've had
this conversation before about the
patriots players
who
are going to make it to the hall of fame
out of this group that has put together
this incredible run
in this decade
who are the hall of famers other than
tom brady and bill belichick who jumps
off the page gronk is the first one who
jumps off the page and even though you
know tight ends don't automatically get
shoved into the hall of fame
there's a very good argument to be made
that he's the best tight end of all time
and i think that they both get in and
between the two i go back and forth but
i think gronk was a bigger star than
peppers ever was and the fact that he's
got the hardware the super bowl wins
that's the thing that makes the
difference and would get him in before
pepper so i reluctantly agree with you
yeah i i hear you it is it's a tough one
i mean because we're talking about an
all-time legend i mean
legends freaks and nature julius peppers
again mike like i've said about a lot of
guys or a few guys i should say not a
lot of guys but like gronk was one of
those people when you ran on the field
and saw julius peppers the first time
and the first time i saw him was my
junior year at texas we were playing
north carolina and i remember running
out to the to the 50-yard line and we're
going to get ready to do a little pat
and go and get warmed up and julius
peppers was there and
like i did with clayus campbell the
first time i saw him i literally looked
at him and said holy crap you're big and
you know i kind of like tried to have
fun with them that way i just couldn't
get over the size of the individual uh
true specimen and like i said he was a
guy that made me look over uh or look
out the corner of my eye a whole lot
when i was in tampa bay and he was with
the carolina panthers
six seven two ninety five played for the
panthers bears packers and then panthers
one more time nine time pro bowler
three-time first-team all-pro
defensive rookie of the year
uh all-decade team oh did he ever lead
the league in sacks though i don't know
ever did i feel like he's been around 12
and 13 a whole lot in the top five
conversation but man mike i saw him have
one in one-handed interceptions and
return it for touchdowns the thing i
always appreciated appreciated about him
i knew when he did hit me on the blind
side he wasn't gonna just kill me and
annihilate me he actually had like
feelings and compassion for the
quarterback to a degree where like he
would crush you and then like peel you
off the turf and pick you up and like
give you a slap on the butt like hey
good job for getting up i'll be back in
a few minutes so uh i love julius
peppers and the way he approached the
game i do got to say that
all right quick break when we return
we're going to answer your questions on
this tuesday edition of pft live we'll
be back with more right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports